الان معنا من غزه الدكتور اشرف القدره
المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه في قطاع غزه
دكتور اشرف ما اخر ما وصلكم من ارقام عما
خلفه هذا القصف وهذه المجزره في مخيم
المغازي بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم من الواضح
ان ما يحدث في مخيم المغازي هي عباره عن
اباده جماعيه لمربع سكني بالكامل حيث ان
هذا المربع تم قصف
عده بيوت بداخله ولكن كل بيت به عشرات
العائلات التي نزحت اليهم من اماكن مختلفه
من قطاع غزه وبالتالي هذه المجزره كبيره
جدا حتى اللحظه ما وصل الينا 70 شهيد من
كاف من هذه المجزره ومن هذه الاباده
والعدد مرشح لزياده لان الطواقم المختصه
في الدفاع المدني وسيارات الاسعاف لازالت
تقوم بمحاوله انتشال الضحايا من تحت
الركام ولكن هناك صعوبه في الوصول الى
الضحايا بسبب كثره الانقاض وبسبب وعوره
المكان وبسبب قله الامكانيات المتاحه لدى
قوات الدفاع المدني والمكين وبالتالي هذا
العدد مرشح للزياده خلال الساعات القادمه
اذا ما توصلت هذه القوات قوات الدفاع
المدني وسيارات الاسعاف الى انتشال ال
جسامين الشهداء من تحت الانقاض او
المصابين من تحت الانقاض
اضافه الوصول الى هذه الاماكن اذا اذا ما
جددنا التذكير بهذا الخبر العاجل بان
مقاتلات اسرائيليه تجدد غاراتها على
مخيمات ايضا وسط قطاع غزه وبالتالي ايضا
ربما هذه الليله ايضا ستحمل ايضا
استهدافات اخرى في اماكن اخرى في وسط قطاع
غزه غير ما جرى في مخيمي المغازي
والبريج من الواضح ان هناك استهدافات
مركزه في المنطقه الوسطى وقلنا قبل قليل
بان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يقوم بجمع
المواطنين باتجاه الاماكن التي يدعي انها
امنه ثم يقوم باستهدافها بشكل مركز مما
يوقع عدد كبير من الضحايا في الاماكن
المختلفه من قطاع غزه المشكله الاكبر من
ذلك هو عدم توفر الخدمه الصحيه الكافيه
لهذه الاعداد الكبيره في مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى الوحيد في المنطقه الوسطى حيث ان
كل الشهداء الذين وصلوا الان هم ملقون على
في ساحه المستشفى لا يوجد مكان لاحتضانهم
في ثلاجات الموتى اضافه نشاهد ما ذكرته
الان دكتور اشرف بصور مباشره ايضا لجثامين
الشهداء في مستشفى شهداء الاقصى تفضل نعم
اضافه الى ان الاصابات يفترشون الارض الان
نسبه الانشغال السريري في مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى بلغت 300% وبالتالي الجرحى يفترشون
الارض والطواقم الطبيه تحاول انقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه ولكن بما يتوفر لديها من
امكانيات متواضعه لان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
لازال يتعنت في ادخال المساعدات الطبيه
وفق اولويات وزاره الصحه والهدف من ذلك هو
ابقاء المنظومه الصحيه في حاله انهيار
مستمر حتى لا تقوى الطواقم الطبيه على
انقاذ حياه الجرحى وبالتالي ترتفع فاتوره
العدوان بمزيد من الضحايا حتى في داخل
مستشفيات قطاع غزه الواقع الصحي في جنوب
قطاع غزه كارثي للغايه ووصل الى مستويات
في الانهيار غير مسبوقه وهذا يدلل بان
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لديه سياسه واضحه في
تصفيه الوجود الصحي سواء في شمال قطاع غزه
او في جنوب القطاع ماذا عن التعامل مع
الجرحى وهم ايضا كثر وحالاتهم حرجه قبل قل
كانت هناك دعوه لفتح المعابر كملجا اخير
من اجل انقاذ من يمكن انقاذه نتيجه هذا
القصف يعني للاسف العدد الهائل من
الاصابات وعدم توفر الامكانيات السريه
والبشريه والدوائيه تجعل الطواقم الطبيه
في هذه الاثناء تقوم بعمليه مفاضله واضحه
بين الحالات لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه من
الحالات التي ممكن ان يتم انقاذها وهذا
يفقدنا العشرات من الحالات التي كان
بالامكان انقاذ حياتها لو توفرت
الامكانيات المطلوبه على مستوى اقسام
العمليات والعنايات المكثفه واقسام
الطوارئ وكذلك ايضا توفرت القدره السريه
في هذه المستشفيات وبالتالي نحن امام
كارثه حقيقيه سيدفع ثمنها الجرحى بمزيد من
الشهداء خلال الساعات القاد اذا ما اشتد
العدوان على المنطقه الوسطى كما نشاهد في
هذه الاثناء لان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يدرك
تماما لان المنظومه الصحيه في المنطقه
الوسطى هشه تماما ولا تقوى على استقبال
المزيد من هؤلاء الضحايا سواء من الشهداء
او الجارحى طيب ذكرت قبل قليل بان نسبه
الاشغال على سبيل العينه في مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى هي 300 بال وبالتالي الان وحن
نشاهد هذه الصور لجثامين الشهداء وهم كثر
اكيد ان ليس هناك ثلاجات للتكفل بهذه
الجثامين وبالتالي ماذا عن مصير هذه
الجثامين امام هذا الوضع الحرج للمستشفيات
يعني للاسف الوضع كارثي للغايه في داخل
مستشفى شهد الاقصى هو مستشفى صغير
ومساحاته ضيقه نحن نخشى ان يقوم الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بنفس السلوك الاجرامي الذي
توجه به الى مستشفيات شمال قطاع غزه ويقوم
بتكرار نفس السيناريو حاصره هذه المستشفى
بمزيد من الاستهدافات في محيطها حتى لا
تستطيع الطواقم الطبيه الخروج من هذه
المستشفى لانتشار الضحايا او الدخول اليها
وكذلك يصعب على المواطنين اخراج شهدائهم
وبالتالي تتحول هذه المستشفى كسابقاتها من
مستشفيات الشمال قطاع غزه الى مقابر الى
مقبره جماعيه وهذا ما يريده الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هو يريد ابقاء المنظومه الصحيه
في حاله انهيار يريد للطواقم الطبيه ان
تبقى عاجزه امام هذا الكم الهائل من
الشهداء والجرحى وبالتالي الاحتلال يمعن
في تصفيه الوجود الصحي واستكمال حلقات
انهياره بشكل واضح على سبيل المثال هل
هناك بنك للدم او طريقه للتبرع بالدم
عندما نتكلم عن حرب عندما نتكلم عن كل هذا
العدد من الجرحى فالاكيد هناك حاجه كبيره
وكبيره جدا للدم لانقاذ من يمكن انقاذه
كيف تتعاملون فيما يتعلق بهذا الموضوع
نحن نقوم باسترش شاد المواطنين وتوجيههم
الى المستشفيات وبنوك الدم من اجل التبرع
بالدم ولكن كل ما يتم التبرع به يتم
استنزافه نتيجه الجراحات الغائره ونتيجه
النزف المستمر
للمصابين كل مصاب يحتاج الى كميات كبيره
من الدم وبالتالي نحن طالبنا المؤسسات
الامميه و وعلى راسها اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر بتوفير كميات دم من الاماكن
المجاوره من خارج قطاع غزه حتى يتسنى
للطواقم الطبيه العمل بمقتضى انقاذ حياه
الجرحى وبالتالي الموجود في داخل مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى كميات قليله لا تتناسب مع
حجم الاصابات التي تصل الى مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى وخاصه ان الاحتلال يركز عدوانه
خلال هذه الساعات على المنطقه الوسطى بشكل
كبير طيب انتم وكذلك المنظمات الدوليه بل
كل العالم يقول بان القطاع الصحي في قطاع
غزه تجاوز مرحله الانهيار هل ما يصلكم حتى
الان ربما يعني كيف تقيمون ما يصلكم حتى
الان في اطار دخول المساعدات بالنظر لما
يحدث وما
يجري تاكيد الواقع الصحي لازال يشهد
انهيارا مستمرا في كافه مناطق قطاع غزه
خاصه في جنوبه لان منطقه الشمال وصلت الى
حد تصفيه الوجود الصحي من قبل الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي فلا يوجد خدمات صحيه في شمال
القطاع وكل الجرحى الذين يسقطون في شمال
قطاع غزه ينزفون حتى الموت اما في جنوب
قطاع غزه النيار مستمر نحن نتحدث عن عدم
توفر سعه سريريه نحن نتحدث عن عدم توفر
امكانيات دوائيه حتى في غرف العمليات
والعنايات المكثفه نحن نتحدث ايضا عن عدم
توفر قدرات بشريه الطواقم البشريه التي
تعمل في المستشفيات اقل من 30% على اكصر
حد وبالتالي لا يوجد ق رات طبيه في داخل
مستشفيات جنوب قطاع غزه اضافه الى ان
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لازال يتحكم في حجم
ونوعيه ومسار المساعدات الطبيه والانسانيه
التي تدخل الى قطاع غزه ويستخدم هذه
المساعدات كسلاح اضافي لقتل المزيد من
الجرحى في داخل مستشفيات قطاع غزه حينما
تعجز هذه الطواقم عن انقاذ حياه جرحى قطاع
غزه وبالتالي نحن دعونا كافه الاطراف
للعمل على ايجاد ممر انساني امن يسمح
بتدفق المساعدات الطبيه الى مستشفيات قطاع
غزه ويسمح ايضا بتشغيل مستشفى مجمع الشفاء
الطبي حتى يكون الامل الوحيد لمنطقه شمال
قطاع غزه اضافه الى وجود ممر امن لخروج
اكثر من 5000 جريح دفعه واحده الى خارج
القطاع هؤلاء اذا بقوا في القطاع فاننا
سنشهد المئات الذين يفقدون حياتهم يوميا
في داخل مستشفيات قطاع غزه لعدم توفر
العلاج المناسب للحالات الخطيره والحرجه
والمعقده ارجو ان تبقى معي دكتور اشرف
لاقرا هذا الخبر العاجل نقلا عن مراسل
الجزير اعداد كبيره من سكان مخيم البريج
ينزحون من منازلهم لمراكز الاواء مع
استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي دكتور اشرف
وكاننا امام السيناريو ايضا يتكرر مره
اخرى كالذي جرى في المناطق الشماليه من
قطاع غزه ما الذي تحذرون منه العالم وهل
تتوقعون ان يتحرك المجتمع الدولي هذه
المره على عكس ما جرى في الشهرين
الماضيين نحن للاسف اصبنا بخيبه امل من
العالم باثره ومن المجتمع الدولي الذي
تسيطر عليه الاداره الامريكيه بالفيتو
المقرر من اجل ابقاء الحاله حاله الاباده
الجماعيه في قطاع غزه من قبل الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي المجتمع الدولي عاجز
تماما على تحقيق اي هدف من من اجل انقاذ
ما يمكن انقاذه في قطاع غزه سواء بوقت
اطلاق النار او بادخال المساعدات الطبيه
والانسانيه الى قطاع غزه نحن اذا طلبنا
نطلب بدايه من الله عز وجل ان نوقف هذا
العدوان وثم نطلب من شعوب العالم الحر بان
يضغطوا على حكوماتهم من اجل وقف هذا
العدوان وان يسمحوا بالدخول المساعدات
الطبيه والانسانيه الى قطاع غزه وكذلك
دخول الفرق الطبيه من حول العالم لتصل الى
مستشفيات قطاع غزه وتقوم على انقاذ حياه
الجرحى اضافه الى توفيق المستشفيات
الميدانيه لتصل الى كافه مناطق قطاع غزه
من اجل انقاذ حياه الجرحى الذين يسقطون
بالالاف في هذا العدوان المستمر شكرا لك
الدكتور اشرف القدره المتحدث باسم وزاره
الصحه في قطاع غزه